time to draft the people under the most
pressure as we enter week 14 big cat
you've got the trivia question that
determines the first pick all right Mike
despite their loss last night the
Cowboys are still in first place in the
NFC East with a 6 and 7 record who was
the last team to win a division with a
losing record Seattle Seahawks 2010 7 &
9 Ron Rivera is right in front of you
forgot about that 7 8 & 1 2014 7 8 & 1
you're right
back to back to back the middle back was
not all that impressive but they still
won the division all right go ahead take
the first pick that is funny that he's
talking about back to back to back it
was 7 8 & 1
oh man that connected perfectly alright
my first pick it's an easy one the most
pressure this weekend how about the
Patriots wide receivers Patriots wide
receivers after having a poor game on
Sunday Night Football after Tom Brady
yelling at them it's clear that they are
the weakest link when it comes to this
Patriots team you could probably throw
in the offensive line as well but
getting separation on Sunday making Tom
Brady's job easier is clearly focused
here for the Patriots so I think they're
under pressure to perform to step up and
help their quarterback hopefully get in
the win column there yeah and you know I
had Tom Brady on my list I'm not gonna
make him one of my picks cuz this is
part of the you know purpose to have the
conversation about the game I think he's
under pressure because people are
starting to pay closer attention to how
much of the problem he is that's one of
the things Sims was beating on all week
the idea that Brady never gets
criticized and maybe he is part of the
problem and and maybe he isn't but I
think now that this has kind of reached
full boil with him giving those guys the
business on the sideline last Sunday
night against the Texans I think that
people are gonna be watching more
closely everything Brady does and he's
got the elbow injury and the toe injury
and he he suggested last night to Jim
Gray of Westwood one that it's no big
deal but I think we're gonna watch Brady
more carefully he's out there on the
field again matching with Patrick
mahomes and if he does not play well
more people are going to say
maybe he's part of the problem we'll
also throw in there with those video
clips Tom Brady's barber is maybe under
pressure because he went a little heavy
on the dye job there
that's not die what are you talking
about that's not die okay okay that is
the my stroke I dye my hair he's wearing
white you dye your hair we're two guys
that Dyer hey I don't first of all I
don't dye my hair second of all I'm
saying that's the natural color of the
hair system that he has it's not dying
okay okay all right yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna go Carson Wentz Carson Wentz in
Philly if the game Monday night was in
New York no pressure and the Eagles fans
are not going to be satisfied at all by
the fact that the Cowboys lost they
don't care there is angry as any fan
base right now the Eagles have looked
horrible and if they stumble around in
the first half against the Giants who
are not good with Eli Manning dust it
off and oiled up like the tin man and
put back out on the field they are gonna
hear it loudly and it's good you know it
will affect at some point it's gonna
affect them that that fan base they are
gonna be ready to pounce on the Eagles
if they it's the exact opposite of Jerry
Jones who's like hey we're still alive
the Eagles fans aren't gonna care and
whence has got to bring it on Monday
night or it's gonna get ugly in
Philadelphia an oiled up Eli Manning got
it
that's we're not oiled up like like he's
doing a pose down like oiled up like
he's he's the he can't you know he sees
the 10-man he good pick good pick I
actually didn't even see this one
because I didn't think we were doing
Monday Night Football but that's a good
pick I'll go I'll stay in New York I'm
gonna say the Jets because the Jets we
talked about this with the Bears how
they're gonna finish this season how
they need positive momentum going into
next season they might not make the
playoffs it's still a long shot but
anything that you can get that can get
you into the next season is good when
you have a young quarterback young coach
the Jets are in that spot the Jets after
Sam Donald says they're gonna run the
table they win three in a row they score
34 points each game
they look like everything's clicking
they go to oh and 11 Cincinnati drop an
absolute egg don't score touch
down on offense I think this is a big
game for the Jets future they're not
gonna go to the playoffs this year but I
think the future of the Jets the future
of Sam Donald this is the type of game
that if they have another clunker in a
row and they lose back-to-back games
against the worst teams in football and
they lose two games to the Dolphins this
season things are gonna not feel so
great for the Jets coming out on Monday
I mean Adam GaSe has already been told
he's gonna be back next year but I I
agree with you to the extent that you
want to finish strong I mean this is the
time of year where we see some of these
teams that are out of it what kind of
momentum can they build in December that
carries over assuming the coach is back
assuming the key players are back and
for the Jets the coach is gonna be back
the key players are gonna be back and
you need look you need to sell tickets
and if you come out of December feeling
like hey maybe the Jets are on to
something maybe more people buy tickets
and the craziest thing about this game
Mike if the Dolphins beat the Jets they
will have a worse draft pick than them
as crazy as it sounds because the
Dolphins were trying to tank all year
but that would be 4 and 8 and 4 and 8
and they'd have both wins against the
Jets so it's a little weird how the
schedule has worked out all right I am
going to go with a guy that we saw in
the opening he has made it clear that he
needs to improve he's had two horrible
games back to back on the road against
the Jets and against the Kansas City
Chiefs and that's Derek Carr and look
the Raiders are still alive they're six
and six the Titans are coming into town
for the wait for it big cat penultimate
game at the Oakland Coliseum they got to
win these games and Derek cars got to
play better and if not Andrew Luck's
gonna be the quarterback of the Las
Vegas Raiders next year so it's on car
to put himself in a position where he
actually is gonna live in that house
he's building next door to Jon Gruden in
Vegas ah good pick cuz I actually had
this pick so I like this pick a lot I
think the Raiders it it's very very
weird what's happened the last two weeks
with them because statistically they
were actually not bad against the Chiefs
they add more yards than the Chiefs but
they got blown out in the scoreboard and
the game against the Jets was a total
egg so yeah this is a this is a get
right game for the Raiders otherwise
this season is over all right
mine last pick Mike let me
pause a second we got we got some extra
time it really is not crazy to atleast
ponder the possibility of Jon Gruden
deciding when it's time to upgrade at
quarterback he doesn't want to deal with
rookies we heard that every year in
Tampa Bay he didn't want to deal with
Simms he had nothing to do with drafting
Simms he wants a veteran who comes in
who is smart who can run his offense and
who can get it done and Andrew Luck is
out there and if Andrew Luck decides
after a year out of football he wants to
come back
Gruden will move heaven and earth to try
to get him onto the Raiders will he pull
it off
I don't know first step is luck has to
want to come back but that was the whole
genesis of this conversation yesterday I
just got this weird feeling and if I'm
Jon Gruden I'm trying to get Andrew Luck
he's the best available quarterback out
there and he's sitting on a couch
alright go ahead make your pick you
don't think that the Jim Irsay would
have a big issue with that
well you trade for him trade for him
they Jacobi / sets their guy okay Jacobi
verse that's their guy that's fine okay
I'll throw out another name for the
Raiders what about a trade for Drew
Brees he's gonna be a free agent sitting
up straight for him oh there you go I
was actually joking I was just trying to
take you uh-huh
how about deshaun Watson in Las Vegas
but what buddy skis under contract the
text I sent you another joke okay all
right who's sleep-deprived here I'm just
moans yeah that's a good call I'm
running off the Bears win it's fueled me
it's given me extra life alright my last
pick Mike I am going to go with oh I
don't know I have a couple here you know
what let's go with the Minnesota Vikings
your Minnesota Vikings we talked about
this game in the first hour the Vikings
season has been very good the Vikings
season has been also when you look back
at the schedule very similar to what
Kirk Cousins does he beats up on bad
teams and he loses to the good teams so
if that's gonna continue they should
beat up on the Lions and they should get
right here and this is one of those
games where now they can't really slip
up here because they have
the Packers and Bears week 16 and 17
they need to be focused they need to win
this game and I know they obviously
don't have a ton of pressure because
they're eight and four and they're much
better team than the Lions but you said
it yourself
they were down against the Broncos and
if they slip up it will be big big
problem for the Vikings yeah you know
you you you apparently don't watch or
listen to the show on the days you
aren't on you committed the ultimate
faux pas twice you know pick teams you
give me a person okay person that's the
whole team
all right that's Xavier Rhodes and
you're right and you're right yeah
forget about him it's Kirk Cousins
without questions Kirk Cousins because
you're it's you know look in hindsight
that went over the Cowboys isn't nearly
as impressive as it was at the time
because the Cowboys stink they've got to
deliver against the teams they should
beat and they got to lay the foundation
it's not just who they should beat it's
the circumstance a lot is riding on this
the Bears are back the Rams are there
they need this win and when we saw the
table was set a couple of weeks ago to
coast into the by weekend about 20
points to the Broncos and they put
themselves in a tough spot they can't
afford to do that again
alright I'm gonna go I'm either going
Derek Carr or not to her car going to
Derek Carr Drew Brees or Jimmy Garoppolo
and I'm leanin breeze breeze at home
against an elite team brand and it's not
just can Brees make the throws at the
right time is Brees gonna buy into
whatever Sean Payton can [ __ ] to beat
the 49ers check the ego at the door
let taste some he'll throw the ball not
shutting in then Brees knows how to how
to play the game and not show
frustration he knows the cameras gonna
be on him but can he do everything
that's expected of him and willingly not
do more than what they want him to do if
they are gonna showcase Taysom Hill if
he is the secret ingredient to beating
the 49ers I just think Brees has to be
completely locked in dialed in and fully
accepting of what could be a reduced
role because a reduced role for Brees
may be the only way they're gonna beat
the 49ers Mike I really like that pic I
think that's a great pick I you also see
who drew Drew Brees has
played since he has come back beat the
Cardinals lost the Falcons beat the Bucs
Panthers and Falcons so not exactly
murderers row of teams here this is his
first big test since he has come back
I like that pick I think Drew Brees is
definitely under pressure this week
because the Saints this is going to be
the game where we decide are the Saints
really for real here not just because if
they win they could be the inside track
for a home-field advantage in the dome
but if they win this game we're gonna
come away thinking okay the Saints can
be a very top level top high level
opponent and Drew Brees still does have
some juice left in this tank
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports